hello everybody and welcome to the very
last part of Anna okay so we got the
whole colors all in order everything
looking good very Google s and we need
to get over there here we go oops no
fail FAL huh there we are
a hard light bridge Thank You mr. portal
[Music]
yeah winner is more cave I didn't see
that back there hello
I solved the mask of the divine hello
those drawings were telling her story
and mine as well yes all right I'm
guessing I should follow the candles but
I'm curious that's me was me all along
oh all the hands oh oh
it's those fertility dolls okay all
right get in there get in there get in
there
all right so I'm gonna go the other way
the candles there's some red down there
then you go here first oh boy oh boy
[Music]
then by little I advance
let me save you save real quick okay
nothing alright so maybe I need to
unlock something to get through there I
don't know
oh I thought I was like for sure that
something was gonna happen
sealing there it's that same symbol that
was in the house two one dark I wouldn't
let my kids actually is that a dead end
there's a face in the wall
oh my goodness
[Music]
Oh My lordy Lou oh it's got eyes no no
no no no no no no no they were supposed
to stab it in the eyes or something I
don't know let me try good that
brilliant idea to do shut up
okay nevermind I'm out of here screw
that screw everything about that oh why
does it have to scream even if it's just
a quiet screaming there's a furnace
I can now remember every moment we spend
together oh oh it's Chris oh no it's
like it had one leg oh hello I curse
Tony I you stare at me and yet you know
well why I am here soon I too shall
learn this you do not desist don't you
realize it is too late I am into your
womb where else could I go you do not
okay I have the stone okay it's two
different things
no dice let me stab ya that's logical Oh
I got it I got the eye of stone I got
the Ives did I do what was that I think
that's doing anything okay whatever okay
okay okay did I try putting the mask on
this and I just want to check okay all
right I'll have an eye use the eye on me
I've got no ball back off
oh don't like so many things in this I
don't like I have a strange idea that
I'm gonna try and was the eye in the
mouth of that thing is that's logical
what the hell
a handli read that for us I feel the
warmth of thy pitying gaze upon my face
you tried to redeem me and I'm so
grateful if there's no coming back
yep okay ah I didn't I didn't pick up
any hints on that one guys that was this
crazy idea that I thought I don't know
what I'm thinking what are you thinking
[Music]
okay I can't go in there it's actually
pushing me away of it
getting closer seems like it's wrapping
around me okay I have fine okay oh maybe
I put the eye back in the stone thing
cuz I don't think there was anything
over there let me try that okay
I'm staying way away from you douche
nozzle I swear and no matter what this
is gonna be the last episode so I'm just
gonna keep going until it ends and
that's it but I think I'm close to the
end here if this isn't it then go back
and find something else there we go
something happening where are those
noises from there's a maelstrom of
thoughts into my head
this place is telling me my own story
fantastic was I married then I don't
know why would I know
okay so I can't get at the eye anymore
the eyes go in there I bet I can go down
the dark dome again
[Music]
hmm there's a light behind the corner
mm-hmm it seems a candle yeah that's not
really when I stole her statue from the
church there were a lot of Castle
candles statue well as if they were
singing ring around the roses around
Anna my wife became blind with jealousy
blithering idiot woman she could never
be as charming as Anna was is Anna
statue nobody else can ever be okay
candles an ocean of candles they are
piercing my eyes I remember what
happened as if it were just happened
right now you were doing so good in the
grammar the candles outlined her marble
body so white and pure that woman dared
did to face it with a hammer curse her
curse you I still feel my battery body
shivering and anger those dead bodies oh
look it's the mask I found you my
darlings Oh
I had to do it I should have you were
screaming I could not bear it anymore
but I'm here now
and I'll protect you forever and oh oh
I'm caved in that's lovely
here and now I meet my destiny no one
will ever separate us again you are as
beautiful as I remembered this guy's in
love with a statue and I love you still
okay all right
that guy's crazy not so crazy not so
what I don't know is how he forgot
everything in the first place that's
what I want to know what I don't get is
where did the wife come into all this
who's a story of the pic things about
the Statue or was it about his wife I'm
not exactly sure
obviously he sold a statue to church
they like works if it is those kids were
real
everything was in his head like
everything was just him being a giant
insane piece crap so
[Music]
that's what I'm wondering he lived in
this Shack alone in the woods and for
some reason he didn't remember what
happened in Olson the deeper he goes
into his own memories the crazier he
gets so maybe like he got help that he
was sane once after
[Music]
I don't know maybe he killed his wife a
lease or whatever nobody came back
but obviously there was death and murder
I'm worried about that this guy did it
why and all these whole stories the main
character the crazy son of a [ __ ]
Daniel that pretty much I can't remember
right now but either way that was
scariest friend I mean just the
atmosphere I then worked a lot of scares
in the game I just scared the living
hell out of myself and that's what makes
a good organ it's not that you are
scared by what's happening to you it's
that you're doing things that you don't
want to and that scary your mind is
making up everything else that's what
scared that was scary
over that last part nothing jumped out
at me nothing can happen there was no
chump stare I was just creeped out out
of my mind that that stone carving in
the wall I didn't want to get here and I
just thought it was gonna come out
[Music]
man
anyway macabre marketing videos hate
away
did a really good job I mean I had
obviously very very in me excuse me
who's been on the unity engine which is
hey you know free the use engine no
royalties just user at least I think
there might be simple loyalties once you
make a certain amount of money I'm not
sure if I'm free to develop all the
tools are there available come with the
Unreal Engine the Unreal Engine is
actually free for everyone to use the
whole developer kit is free for me to
use and you can publish a game up to two
if you make over two hundred and fifty
thousand dollars with the game that's
when you have to play room so that's why
the Unreal Engine is so prolific right
now the way the game was have some bugs
like stability issues but everything
else I mean it was very old school very
old school adventure
and click everything to everything yeah
the kid you got clues that you didn't
know what to do and you just have to
experiment with that I had to rely on a
lot of you guys Intel so thank you for
that man Ellis
the guy who made this congratulations
great game if you want to apply it it's
only ten dollars but it's coming to
steam so soon the guy said he was coming
to this game I had to buy it on asura
which is like the same program that
everything uses on come on baby
Monte B is where a lot I get a lot of
the image
custom suit so it's a digital society
and the program is a bad button if you
don't want to have multiple
you don't need to buy
anyway I think we're coming to the end
of it my painful cervical one I just
read one of the special thanks and that
was very interesting and weird anyway
anyway great game great game I'm really
I'm really happy that I played this one
and thank you everyone for suggesting is
if you ever have another suggestion for
an indie game that's like you know small
unheard of I'd love to try give it a try
I mean the some of those small ones are
just the best titles amnesia started out
very small I mean no one had heard of
penumbra before you know when frictional
games first made it so you gotta give
these guys a chance
I think dream painters is the name of
the company if it's coming up here dream
paint ups get a dream painters so I
wouldn't be surprised of use but if you
could see more it really is cool then
you can get that's why I'd like let's
place it gets attention to love these
smaller things and even a small youtuber
like
help add to the ad Italy
for being permitted anyway
credits are closing I've been rambling
for parking once again if you have
suggestions for another
[Music]
game or game or something like that
doesn't happen
let me know in the comments or write me
a message on YouTube right now suit you
better
anyway that's it thank you all so much
for watching and as always wait hang on
I want to see if there's something at
the end I made it all this way so I
might as well
[Music]
anything up nope that's it okay thank
you everybody so much for watching I do
appreciate each and every one of you and
as always I will see you bye-bye